le centre de clairefontaine camp de base
des bleus pendant l'euro 2016 a été en
partie rénové un bâtiment de 5200 mètres
carrés a été inaugurée au mois d'avril à
côté du château
la structure permettra notamment de
recevoir les journalistes pendant les
conférences de presse des joueurs
tricolores sur le plan sportif les bleus
pourront profiter d'infrastructures de
haut niveau pour s'entraîner et
récupérer pendant la compétition
les terrains les espaces de musculation
et le centre médical labellisé fifa ont
été modernisées pour l'euro pour les
joueurs ce qui viennent s'entraîner il
faut qu'ils avaient une qualité terrain
aussi bonne que dans les grands clubs de
séries joueurs de haut niveau donc
aujourd'hui l'effort a été fait sur tous
les terrains en gazon
l'afld exceptionnel qualitatif ça c'est
important aussi au niveau médical on est
bien équipé au niveau technique de
récupération des parts dans l'équipe et
je pense qu'on est au niveau de
satisfaction pour le niveau pour rénover
ce site de 56 hectares ouverts depuis
1988 6 millions d'euros ont été investis
sur trois ans les joueurs de l'équipe de
france ont glissé quelques idées pour
améliorer les équipements et à des
échanges bien évidemment par rapport aux
besoins qui peuvent avoir
et après c'est en discussion aussi avec
avec mon staff staff technique et staff
médical et après évidemment c'est
toujours validé par par la fédération
par rapport au coût des travaux mais
on a toujours eu des personnalités août
pour nous faire en sorte de nous mettre
dans les meilleures conditions
les tricolores vont s'installer dans
leur camp de base à partir du 5 juin
avant de commencer la compétition le
vendredi 10 juin contre la roumanie au
stade de france